continuez à parler de l'impact de la
crise sanitaire sur le secteur de la
culture avec david henochsberg président
du groupe et toiles cinéma je souhaite
équiper un bonjour et merci d'être
heures en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors le déconfinement des salles de
cinéma est censée intervenir le 15
décembre mais les indicateurs sont
mauvais le profil mans pourrait se
prolonger c'est un scénario catastrophe
que vous redoutez way totalement
catastrophe non plus on arrive à la
période de noël qui est la période forte
pour nous ça serait absolument
dramatique on a vécu une première fois
trois mois de fermeture là on va perdre
ça va faire bientôt un plus d'un mois
qu'on est fermée donc la soul est restée
fermée à partir du 15 décembre à nouveau
pour une période indéterminée serait
absolument catastrophique pour notre
secteur
justement est ce que vous comprenez un
fait réflexion sur le monde de la
culture en général
avec l'argent qu'il aurait pu exister de
nombreuses solutions pour limiter les
risques sanitaires
écoutez déjà on avait un protocole
sanitaire qui était extrêmement strictes
on n'a pas eu vent de contamination dans
les cinémas ou dans les théâtres
maintenant on comprend qu'ils aient une
épidémie qui est national mondiale et
que tout le monde doit faire des efforts
pour pour maîtriser cette épidémie
maintenant avec un protocole sanitaire
comme on avait un siège d'écart entre
chaque groupe entre chaque personne
le port du masque obligatoire le gel
hydroalcoolique l'air qui est renouvelé
dans la salle de cinéma
voilà tout est mis en place pour pouvoir
aller au cinéma extrêmement sereinement
donc voilà donc là effectivement si on
doit pas ouvrir le 15
d'abord un on le comprendrait pas et 2
ça serait absolument catastrophique pour
notre secteur catastrophique pour le
secteur fait là aussi apporterez un coup
un coup dur au moral des français
justement
le secteur vit actuellement une année
très dure à quel point cette crise vous
at elle impacté financièrement on est on
est aidé quand même on a un système des
dents france qui est extrêmement bien
fait pour la culture et je peux vous
dire que malgré tout malgré les
difficultés malgré les pertes qui sont
évidemment importantes
moi je suis content d'être entrepreneur
en france cinq ans une fois très clair
maintenant le vrai problème je vais vous
dire on a perdu évidemment beaucoup
d'argent pendant cette période mais
c'est surtout à un moment donné les
aides vont s'arrêter il va falloir
repartir il va falloir que le marché
reprenne
et c'est là où les délais pour les
vraies difficultés vont commencer à
arriver c'est que si on a un marché
moribond qui reprend pas des
distributeurs qui sont timides pour
remettre des films en salle si le marché
américain reprend pas et c'est à ce
moment là la l'ampleur l'ampleur des
dégâts sera absolument colossal pour le
secteur vous parlez des producteurs vous
le sentez déjà justement cette réticence
est timidité à remettre de l'argent pour
produire des des films dans les mois à
venir on va dire non non les producteurs
j'ai l'impression que ça tourne quand
même qu'il ya beaucoup de signes qui se
tourne actuellement la pour les
plateformes vous le cinéma etc
maintenant c'est les distributeurs de
films
il va falloir date les films en salle le
problème c'est quand on a beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur la réouverture sur le
fameux stop and go on a été fermée on a
réouvert on a été refermé donc les
distributeurs qui sont les personnes qui
décident de maxime dans les salles de
cinéma sont assez tétanisés par cette
période parce qu'ils se disent moi je
vais mettre mon fils ça se trouve quinze
jours après le faire fermer mon film
aura pas eu la durée de vie nécessaires
pour pouvoir se rentabiliser voyez c'est
un espèce comme ça de cercle vicieux
moi mon inquiétude c'est que les salles
ne soit pas assez rempli dans le temps
pour permettre de re atteindre un niveau
d'entrée satisfaisant pour notre secteur
et puis vous savez un des problèmes
c'est que là aujourd'hui avec cinéma
sont fermés et vous savez la nature a
peur du vide donc les plateformes se
renforce les films se renforce sur les
plateformes et c'est absolument
retrouver les salles de cinéma pour
combler ce vide
dernière question à votre avis sera-t-il
possible au monde du spectacle de se
relever de cette année noire
ouais je le pense qu'il ya un vrai désir
en tout cas je pense chez les français
de il ya une soif de culture l'art l'a
vu avant la fermeture aux dernières
vacances de la toussaint qui avait une
vraiment belle reprise dans nos salles
de cinéma pas au niveau
on est habituel il y avait quand même
voilà le secteur repartait un pont non
j'ai vu j'ai confiance en la culture et
le cinéma français
même le théâtre en france sont des
choses extrêmement puissante
les gens aiment vraiment le cinéma le
théâtre et on l'a vu en et lorsqu'on a
réouvert qu'un vrai désir je pense qu'on
s'en remettra si on a le contenu
nécessaire prévient en tout cas merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes le président
du groupe étoiles la cinéma